we put our foot down and insisted in
being respected even though a prisoner
she said war you do ask for my name
what's your name you have a limited time
to stay on earth we do not care whether
the cat is black or white as long as it
can catch mice but humility is one of
the most important qualities which you
must have I was paralyzed because it
made my day our attitude towards any
country is determined by the attitude of
that country to our struggle but our
brain said if you don't talk to this man
your country will go up in flames it is
the desire of every freedom fighter to
disappear and by a cloud of glory I
don't know if I have paralyzed you or no
no he was a South African anti-apartheid
revolutionary politician and
philanthropist he served as president of
South Africa from 1994 to 1999 in South
Africa he's often described as the
father of the nation
he's Nelson Mandela and here is top 10
rules for success did you get the braces
guards to treat you with respect
you're in prison and you said I will
only respond to the name Mandela or mr.
Mandela you must fight the battle for
dignity on the very first day you go to
jail really and that's what we did we
put our foot down and insisted in being
respected even though were prisoners and
we've thoughtfully succeeded in that
when I found some place in my country
and a later answer the telephone I then
asked to whom am i speaking
she said you're speaking to me
I said well lady I know I'm speaking to
you but what's your name
she said want you to ask for my name
what's your name I say one lady as soon
as you tell the others I'll tell you
mine but as we argued as to who should
tell his or her name she became very
close and she said you seem to be a
backward person have you passed a metric
now my trick in our country is a
university and reexamination and I said
well lady among the very careful because
if the qualification to speak to you is
the possession of a Madrid certificate I
might work hard and pass my MA trick and
be in the same class as you are that was
treason she said you will never be in my
class and Bank the telephone how I wish
you were here today
she would now discover that I have
achieved more that buzz my mitrik ty
hated oppression and when I think about
the past the type of things they did I
feel angry you have a limited time to
stay on earth you must try and use that
period for the purpose of transforming
your country into what you desire I get
to be what can assure me as a human
being and a concerned african-american
that the anc will indeed have a fiscal
solvent policy that will continue the
use of the resources of South Africa in
a meaningful way or should I put it more
succinctly will your economy be based on
the Marxist system socialism or
capitalism or both I knew that that was
the question you wanted to ask
I am happy that have had the courage to
put it directly we are not concerned
with models we are not concerned with
labels we are practical men and women
whose solutions are today today the
actual conditions existing in our
country as somebody has said we do not
care whether the cat is black or white
as long as it can catch mice the first
thing is to be honest with yourself you
can never have an impact on society if
you have not changed yourself and one of
the most important weapons in changing
yourself is to recognize that peace
ahmed people everywhere in the world one
piece but humility is one of the most
important qualities which you must have
because if you are humble if you make
people realize that her you are no
threat to them then people will embrace
you they will listen to you was Muhammad
Ali a hero
the views well naturally far as boxing
is concerned and what he has done he was
my hero just like Ruben here this is my
hero what did you say to him when he
told you he loved you well I was
paralyzed because he made my day and
so what leaders what leaders of the 20th
century do you admire well I have
answered that question is not the
question of a leader it's a question of
a human being or does something to make
an ordinary individual to feel I am a
human being and I have a future and I
can go to bed feeling strong and full of
hope and you have praised Fidel Castro
as a leader of human rights and said
that Cuba was one of the countries
that's head and shoulders above all
other countries and human rights despite
the fact that documents of the United
Nations and elsewhere show that Cube is
one of the worst
I was just wondering are these your
models of leaders of human rights and if
so would you want a Qaddafi or an era
fad or Castro to be a future president
of South Africa one of the mistakes
which has some political analysts make
is to think that their enemies should be
our enemies
that we can and we will never do we have
our own struggle which were conducting
we are grateful to the world for
supporting our struggle but nevertheless
we are an independent organization with
its own policy and the attitude of every
country towards our attitude towards any
country is determined by the attitude of
that country to our struggle
Yasser Arafat Colonel Gaddafi Fidel
Castro support our struggle to the hilt
there is no reason whatsoever why we
should have any hesitation about Haley
their commitment to human rights as they
are being demanded in South Africa our
attitude is based solely on the fact
that that they fully support the
anti-apartheid struggle they do not
support it only in rhetoric they are
placing resources at our disposal for us
that is the position you'd also said to
me one even you said we made the brain
dominate the blood our emotion said hmm
the white minority is an enemy we must
never talk to them but our brain said if
you don't talk to this man your country
will go up in flames and for many years
to come this country would be engulfed
in rivers of blood so we had to
reconcile that conflict and I want
talking to the enemy was the result of
the domination of the brain of emotions
then you were convicted in 1964 for a
conspiracy against the state and in your
when you pleaded you said that I am
willing to die for this course this is
very tough thing to say yes I had to say
that not from a spirit of bravado but
because I genuinely felt that they were
going to hang us and it is the desire of
every freedom fighter to disappear under
a cloud of glory
wherever that of Fame it is the task of
a freedom fighter when you see that at
the end of your days has come to live
the tradition of bravery determination
to face even death for your principle
and I thought about it it was not
because I was brave but because one had
a duty to perform at at that moment I
have dedicated my life
- this stock
of the article people
I have fought against white domination
and I have against black domination
I have changed the idea of a democratic
and free society in which all persons
will live together in hand with equal
opportunities
et one idea of which I hope to live for
and to see realized but my lord if it
needs be it is an ideal for which I am
prepared to die for anybody would
changes his principles depending on whom
he is dealing that is not a man who can
lead a nation
apparently mr. copper you have not
listened to my argument if you have done
so then you have not been serious in
examining it
I have replied to one of our friends
here that I have refused to be drawn
into the differences that existed
between various communities inside the
USA you have not commented that I am
going to offend anybody by refusing to
involve myself in the internal affairs
of the USA of the USA
why are you so killed that I should
involve myself in the internal affairs
of Cuba Olivia no I expect you to be
consistent I don't know if I have
paralyzed you know
I'm
I'm afraid mr. Mandela that paralysis
does not sit in quite that easily in my
case the point
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Michael B asked
me to so there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next leave
it in the comments below and I'll see
what I can do I'd also love to know
which of Nelson Mandela's top 10 rules
had the biggest impact on you is going
to change your life in some way
leave it in the comments and I'll join
the discussion and one last thing my
goal with this channel is to get into 1
million subscribers so anything that you
can do to think of to share the video
tell friends about it out of the
playlists tweet about it let people know
I'd really really really appreciate it
thank you guys so much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon